- [Voiceover] Potassium sorbate, and they
give us its formula right over here,
has a molar mass of 150 grams per mole.
They put this decimal here to show us
that these are actually
three significant figures.
Even the zero is a significant digit here.
Is commonly added to diet
soft drinks as a preservative.
A stock solution of potassium sorbate,
dissolvent's an aqueous solution here,
of known concentration must be prepared.
A student titrates 45
millileters of the stock solution
with one point two five
molar hydrochloric acid
using both an indicator and a pH meter.
The value of K A for sorbic acid is
one point seven times ten
to the negative fifth.
All right, so let's tackle
this piece by piece.
Write the net ionic equation
for the reaction between
potassium sorbate and hydrochloric acid.
All right, so first off, let's
write the ionic equation,
and then we'll, I'll write
the net ionic equation,
and hopefully you'll see the difference.
So ionic, ionic equation.
And the way we think about ionic equations
is we think about well,
if these are dissolved
in water, it's an aqueous
solution, these are going
to disassociate into their, into ions.
And so we would write
that out on both of the,
on both the reactant and the product side.
So the potassium sorbate,
we can write that as,
it's gonna be a potassium ion dissolved
in an aqueous solution, plus the
C six H seven O two, this is also
going to be an ion dissolved
in the aqueous solution,
plus the hydrochloric acid
will dissolve, so you have
the hydrogen proton dissolved
in the aqueous solution
plus the chloride ion, or
anion I guess we could say it.
so that's going to be
in our aqueous solution,
and then they react.
What happens?
Well, you're going to have the
C six H seven O two react with
the hydrogen proton to get to sorbic acid.
So you're gonna have sorbic acid,
H C six H seven O two,
that's the sorbic acid.
It's going to be in an aqueous solution.
So I took care so far of that and that,
and then you're going to have,
and then you're going to
have your potassium ions,
your potassium ions
and your chloride ions.
It's going to be just like that.
So this right over here
is the ionic equation,
not the net ionic equation.
I have the ions on the reaction,
on the reactant side, and then on
the product side right over here.
And did I, yep, I included everything.
Now you do the net ionic reaction,
you can imagine what's
going to happen here.
I have potassium ions on the left.
I have potassium ions on the right.
I could net them out on both sides.
So let's net them out on both sides.
I have chloride ions on the left.
I have chloride ions on the right.
I could net them out on both sides.
And then I can write
the net ionic equation.
So the net ionic equation,
net ionic equation,
is going to be well, I
have my C six H seven O two
ion dissolved in an aqueous solution.
You combine that with the hydrogen proton
dissolved in the aqueous
solution, and it's going to,
it's going to give us sorbic acid:
H C six H seven O two
in our aqueous solution.
So there you have it.
That is the net ionic equation.